happy day after the day after st.
Patrick's Day which means that you're
finally functional and mobile
congratulations to your body
welcome to one's over when's there a
short I've only done this one so far but
this is gonna be a list of my favorite
things of the moment right now it's not
necessarily the end of the month in fact
it is directly in the middle of the
month but here are some things that I
like that I want to share with you
because the internet is like
kindergarten where you get graded on
bringing in a thing and presenting it to
your class first kiss yes yes yeah is
not your mother's clean freak refreshing
dry shampoo dry shampoo is fantastic for
the days that you don't want to wash
your hair because you are busy or you're
just lazy or you just don't have this
certain standards that other clean girls
have this is for you this stuff takes
all the oils out of the faces of your
hair roots like this watch right ah and
then you shake it up so it doesn't look
like white dust in your hair and then it
absorbs the oil and it smells nice so it
gives the illusion and that you have
hygiene next yes you see I see a piece
yeah I think you put something like this
in a favorite video before I really like
tinted moisturizer and a vino makes a
really great tinted moisturizer and I
just I am NOT as tan as I was before so
I've started using the fair to light
tinted moisturizer and it works well on
me and there's that as information and
also also it is in 2.5 fluid ounces so
you can bring this on a plane you can
carry it onto a plane ain't no them to
get your butts wipes
next this you see yeah you say yeah okay
yep actually don't know if this is one
of my favorites I'm testing it tonight
for the first time this is one of the
Rimmel London's show-off littler
this is in the color little galaxy ah ok
it smells divine
alright Oh like a cat with a plastic bag
I'm into it it smells great tastes great
it goes on smooth and mmm
I like the color of it galaxy there's no
way that you can in this lighting
determine what the actual color is so go
to your local thing that has the thing
and figure out the thing next this key
see yeah he's yeah he's yeah this is
also been in the favourites before but
it's I love it it stripes I love them
they're my favourite colour tank top
long-sleeve shirt another long sleeve
shirt and another long sleeve shirt I
just love solid bold colors next Animus
on I ordered 48 rolls of toilet paper on
Amazon and I could not be happier last
but not least one of my favorite things
this month is the band called Farwest I
know that you guys know I don't know
anything about music but a friend of
mine is in a band called Far West and
they just released an album egg hey so
good and I'm okay ready here let's try
this on for size
friendly is the lead singer of this band
and it's so good and his voice is so
awesome and if you have any interest in
Johnny Cash esque type music I hope that
you take a look into them anyway that's
it well there you go they're my favorite
things for the mid month of March I hope
that you enjoyed it if not write it in
the comments lord knows you will anyway
I don't know one of my other favorite
things is audible.com I've told you guys
this before like every other youtuber is
promoting audible.com and you know what
I'm doing it to because it's the best I
know there's a sea of you out there that
reads but there's also like an ocean out
there of you that maybe don't want to
read and just want something to do the
talking to you and that's where audible
comes in you can listen to audiobooks
and they're great and if you go to
audible.com slash grace your first audio
download is free and you know what I'm
gonna download because I've seen it
everywhere and I haven't read the books
and no one tell anything about it is
divergent
I'm downloading divergent and no one's
saying anything don't you
you did it didn't you I'm so pissed